We love Patterns
We love it when things fall into place when the last piece of the puzzle fits in when a piece of [music] returns
triumphantly to the Tonic
But we also love to be surprised. We'd love to see the rules get broken for the pattern to shift beneath our feet
For the puzzle to refuse to fit together until we look at it from a new angle
This tension between Pattern and surprise keeps our ears pricked up it gives us enough to hold on to but keeps us on our toes
in both Mathematics and music a
classic kind of Pattern comes from symmetry
We say something is symmetric when there is some way we can transform it that keeps it the same
We look about the same if you flip our image in a mirror
But some of our more distant relatives look the same if you rotate them
repeating patterns like these intricate Moorish mosaics from the Alhambra in Spain
Stay the same if we shift them over or if we rotate them
The Dodecahedron one of plato's favorite things stays the same if we rotate it
There are symmetries in higher dimensions as well like this four-dimensional hypercube
The mathematician Emmy nutter discovered that many of the laws of physics are actually symmetries of the universe
There's another kind of symmetry in mathematics
Fractals are things that look the same when we [zoom] in on them where each part looks like a smaller version of the [hole]
They show up in all sorts of places including
ferns
coastlines and this broccoli my daughter brought home from the grocery store [even]
[simple] Mathematics can make fractals take this triangle of Honeycomb and put ones on the outside
Fill in each cell with the sum of the two numbers above it one plus one equals two
One plus two equals three and so on
now color the odd numbers black and the even numbers white
what do we get if
We continue the pattern and zoom out
We see [a] triangle made of three triangles and each one is a smaller version of the original
perhaps the most famous fractal is the Mandelbrot set
Zooming in on different areas reveals endless variety, but always with a smaller copy of the entire set hiding deep inside it
A
Musical fractal is a piece where the theme harmonizes with a slowed down version of itself?
That way the small-scale structure of the piece is
Repeated at a larger grander scale
Johann Sebastian bach love to play [with] symmetry in
His [fugues] the theme is repeated many times in different forms in
The fugue we're going to perform tonight listen for this theme in the horn
Now listen for the upside down version of it in the second trumpet
The slowed down version it in the first trumpet
And the extremely slow down version in the Tuba
Now let's hear how he puts it all together complete with a great visual of this view
you